I think that you can only put on the
screen what you are and and I think that
the way you construct your visual
language I was very fortunate to live in
a very strange time I I was exposed to
my father won and the lottery and he
then became sort of in a Dickensian way
he became a gentleman you know and he
heard that gentleman had libraries so he
bought a library and a huge desk which I
I used he never used and I read he
bought a few encyclopedias he bought an
encyclopedia of health an encyclopedia
of the arts and a collection of books
for for young people you know and and I
read all of that I became a
hypochondriac because III I thought I
have the cirrhosis I knew I have I was
close to getting an aneurysm but I
became incredibly fascinated by the
mechanisms of the body then I read
another encyclopedia that included a
chapter on automatons and then I read
the art and cyclopædia at the same time
that I was hooked on comic books so for
me Monet MANET they got you know Klimt
whoever had an equal value and
attraction to the way I was watching
Jack Kirby or Bernie Wrightson or
Richard Corvin they they they all fear
my visual imagination and finally in the
classics I I realized that my interest
which lady in the Fantastic would guide
me to Victor Hugo with hundred of the
Damned to Dickens with great
expectations to Jane Eyre to Wuthering
Heights to Frankenstein and and and I
just discovered a universe that were
there were no lines lines between hybrid
lowbrow acceptable or not we're
completely burglary and you construct a
language that is unlimited because you
are not you are not self censoring
yourself and and I find I always say
to people that are looking for for their
own identity I say just just really go
by your instinct and and consume as much
variety if you only consume comic books
or pop culture only that you your
language is narrowing that if you
consume it and process it also the fine
arts so to speak and the classical are
the Kira score or ten ever ISM symbolism
whatever school you are attracted to
naturally your language starts forming
it's its own syntax and it's truly
fascinating how that then loosens the
way you you can see the mythic in Jack
Kirby you can see that the the Norse
myths in Jack Kirby and you can see the
Kirby in the North myth and so you you
really I become essentially so hungry
for images my entire life is a
collection of images and my notebooks in
my in my library in my home what I do I
am like a the most massive magpie in the
world that is so in love with the world
that I want to collect everything
beautiful and I want to repurpose it and
and send it again into the world in a
different way so that the creation of
worlds is very instinctive and and it
comes from the fact that you can you can
talk about those worlds as if they were
real in the same way that in my life I
can talk about the Frankenstein monster
with more certainty than many of my
nephews and cousins you know I know him
that well so so you know you just seen
him at your house yeah well he I live I
I live with very strange life-size
figures yes and but but but it's it's
it's I truly believe that then then you
you create you create a world that that
is never I mean I'm never bored ever I
can be alone i can be waiting for you at
a restaurant or an hour and a half and i
i watch people and i watch how they are
dressed i watch how they move and I make
my stories in my head
guy what if he was ordering dessert and
I see that a stain of blood extends
extending on them on the tablecloth and
I see that he's draping and I go oh so
it's very entertaining there's a few
restaurants like that or when I go when
I go with my my kids to the supermarket
we play a game where or I said we used
to say when they were very little we
would do the dialogue of people walking
by and then we would say what do you
think they're doing here doing where do
we are were they going next you know
it's just everything becomes an exercise
in narrative in a beautiful way